so let me read these stories all right
so you have to know
each of these stories one is sounds more
crazy than the other one but let me kind
of go through number one lost your
virginity at 15 to marilyn monroe people
say that's crazy number two you kill the
pedophile
at the hospital at 11. number three mob
kill jfk a lot of people say that mob
killed marilyn monroe you've said that
before pablo escobar intended to kill
you
and your family but he lets you live in
exchange for reenacting a scene from the
godfather
uh well not for that he found out why
john gotti lied to him see john and john
gotti arranged for me to get down there
what happened
one of his guys came into my club in
vegas state street a pablo's pablo's
guys lorenzo morales and he broke a
cristal bottle and stuck it in his
girlfriend's face in my club
i that's how i killed that guy i went to
in self-defense to that to help her
that's written about that's that's how
it's in the paper yeah yeah he cut you
apparently he slipped me
you see your stitches 81 stitches man
because i was agile enough he went from
my neck and i went this way i didn't
know he had the bottle yet
so it wasn't until
two days later i got out of the hospital
laura manas the girl he stabbed thank
god he missed her eye
but i put three right between his
forehead that night boom in front of
150. you didn't do time for that though
you didn't you you were self-defense
yeah and i let everybody know i said
because i told them you hear these
sirens they're coming for you i i never
knew if they were mobbed up who they
were i said so you had no idea who he
was i had no idea i got you so later on
you find out he's linked to pablo
lorenzo morales
it was known they were watching them so
the dea came to see me said johnny you
know where that guy was no
he was one of the top guys
in america for pablo escobar
hello so now i go and they put it they
put it on uh entertainment tonight i
think was the first time the show was on
and you know a love triangle and there's
nothing
there was no love triangle they had it
all wrong
and they you know
i had i got serious phone calls thought
maybe i was getting involved with drugs
i said no i didn't even know the guy
she came to her defense
in your club right but he was a
mariolito
and what they do
any one his brother was the guy was
coming after me they come to defend
but they'll kill your pets your
neighbors
everybody and leave you last
so i go see john gotti who never liked
me really anyway but i knew
some for some reason that he was dealing
with all of them and he arranged for me
to go there
he figured this i'll never come back
you're going there i said yeah i said at
the time i had one daughter i have two
now
and i knew that he had a daughter and
they were going to come my daughter
says i got to straighten this out he got
the story wrong
and he's you're going to go there i said
yeah to wear medellin yeah
that's where i went
the only comfort i had was going to meet
him in a church
so i met him in a church and i'm walking
down the aisle i thought he was there by
himself in an altar up in the front
as i'm walking the pews as i pass them
are creaking and guys are sitting up the
church was loaded with his guys
i mean i don't know why i would think
he'd be there by himself
and that and then he said you johnny
russo i said yeah bang he hit me and
that was that he didn't hit me but
somebody from behind and i woke up in
the cell that he created in that prison
that he himself yeah
i was three floors down with body bags
around me the stinch was ridiculous
and
then i don't know how many hours later
there's a guy clean dressed not in
fatigues i'm sitting in a chair shackled
nude in a chair
and in his hand
he had the making of the godfather
i mean this movie is so crazy in my life
and he said why don't you tell me you
were calling when the godfather that's
my favorite movie is clean him up and
bring him up to the house
so hours later i'm sitting at his dining
room table he's sitting at one of them
at the other end
and he said why did you come here i
swear i did my homework
you have a daughter my age of my
daughter geo and someone's gonna kill
her what would you do
and he got up
he walked over and hugged me and he says
there's very few men like you that would
come here
he's i'll straighten this out
and i thank god i thought he was dead
he's just do me a favor i said anything
you want you want me to cut the grass
wash your car i was kidding now because
i don't get out of there
he said i want to do the scene of the
godfather as a what scene
is the closing scene when michael comes
to see you
i said okay
you want me to write as you know and i
know the whole scene
as you know the whole scene is yeah he's
come up sit up here where he was sitting
because it was closest to the door he
gets up
and now he had henchmen in there around
him anyway
and he walks into me
and i'm sitting where he was sitting he
says
carlo
you got an answer for santini
today i straightened out all family
business
he did the whole scene and does he speak
perfect english is it uh
no but he had the he had the lines right
but so he spoke english
oh yeah escobar oh yeah
and so now you're doing a scene from the
godfather with
pablo escobar and you're playing you
know how hard this is to believe
i don't know do you know like
do you understand like how because
like i've interviewed the guys that
killed pablo if if you would have killed
pablo and pablo he was who to pablo
lorenzo was who
lorenzo was his uh one of his top
leaders
for him to
[Music]
let you go
and let you live if you did do that
johnny that is that has got to be that's
not yeah take if that in a volcano
that's crazy
i mean because the dea proved it they
knew i was there because when i got when
i landed in florida
when he let me go yeah they boarded the
plane like in a movie
and the hostess said nobody get up
somebody has to come on and they came on
the plane there's where's johnny russo i
raised my hand i still had the bandages
on from my neck
they took me off the plane i'm on a
plane going to washington from florida
on their plane nobody's talking to me
so now i got to go to the bathroom they
had me handcuffed 3 500 feet here what
are we doing handcuffs on such can you
take yourself i got to go to the
bathroom so i go to the bathroom and i
come out one of the dea agents standing
near the door says to me
you were calling the godfather right i
said yeah
so he comes out they must have had a bet
unbeknownst to me so that got a little
light
on the plane now they were not like
they said what were you doing with pablo
escobar
i said and they didn't know this talking
about the government don't know what the
states are doing
i said well i killed his guy you did
what i said i killed this guy saturday
night in my club so they went on
get this information and i did
so now i just admitted that i killed
this guy
i'm walking out of there they thought i
was the new guy
what do you mean the new guy
connection for drugs they saw me with
they saw me with gaudy in new york they
watch
everything they see me down there for
two days and i'm walking out
and then they prove that you know
and then i was in washington maybe a
couple hours they checked everything out
everything was proven they said you can
go i we mean go i'm in washington
well yeah
i said i'm going to vegas
we don't
provide transportation i had to get my
own flight to go back to where i was
going
no but i mean they knew
they have records of it
i mean there's there's probably it's a
crazy story i mean here's a robbing 86
million dollars in three hours from six
banks okay you got the shot of iran out
of the country before his regime fell
talking about russia and vladimir putin
having special intel that putin had
exiled steven seagal to siberia that's
right you recorded meeting saddam
hussein when he was tasked with dropping
money off to him in a weapons deal and
you sat in his throne you know
the current status of the mob and said
that the organizations are rebuilding
and adapting
to the times especially in new york
and sicily right the zsa gevor you guys
went on a date and then she ended up
setting you up with a sex with another
woman okay i believe that that's that
bruce yeah the threesomes with who liza
uh mannelly after
both took a liking to the some vegas
show girl oh no bear touch in vegas is
what
she was the star of bad touch of vegas
she was the girl was yeah and liza was
the riviera hotel i remember that
vividly we went over to stardust hotel i
was always over here did you make a love
or was it more like oh it was insane no
we didn't make a lot of we didn't make
love i got you it wasn't one of the
three
you know you were the first person are
you ready for this yeah i still remember
lady's name emelina esquivel
that's who emilita escobar was the
dancer in bad touch in vegas she came
out of this out of the ceiling
in a body suit like a snake coming down
and we'll lead an escalator and and liza
and i were sitting there we both look at
her and we said
we got to have a
but she said and i said that to her and
we took her up to the bridal suite he
always had the bridal suite well nick
niddy just so your audience knows nick
niddy
and i were partners
we were couriers
taking money from vegas
to the vatican we used to go
every other week
we had licenses we weren't doing
anything
illegal and the story you talked about
about the shah yeah your parents
indirectly were involved with that yeah
we talked about that when we were hello
we were in uh how's that yeah when we
spoke about this in uh in uh what do you
call it new york
parents dad not not mom more on the
dad's side so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]